listos empecemos
ok hola nuevamente perdón por aquí el
problemita técnico sabemos que con la
tecnología de repente nos fue un poquito
chueco pero aquí estamos otra vez
bienvenidos a todos a este webinar
número 2 de khan academy estamos muy
emocionados porque tenemos muchas cosas
que compartir con ustedes campeonatos ya
comenzaron ya comenzó el registro a
partir del 13 de agosto ya podemos
registrarnos y tenemos además muchas
cosas nuevas en khan academy que están
pasando y que la verdad nos tiene muy
emocionados porque significa para
nosotros docentes la verdad grandes
avances grandes oportunidades para
todavía ser mejores y tener otras
maneras de enseñar y de compartir con
nuestros alumnos así que vamos a
comenzar
este webinar es el enlace para la
presentación si ustedes tienen su
dispositivo a la mano abran una
ventanita pongan el enlace para que el
día de está para que puedan entrar y el
día de mañana pues tengan esta
presentación baje la para que puedan
verla resolver sus dudas y ya la hagan
suya si no tienen su dispositivo a la
mano tomen una foto con su celular ya
más adelante podrán bajar la pero sí es
importante que la tengan o para que
nuevamente puedan recurrir a esta
presentación las veces que sean
necesarias jeje punto jefe diagonal de d
zh adrianita si puedes ponerla por favor
en el chat estaría súper vamos a
continuar
qué vamos a ver hoy hoy vamos a ver
bueno cómo crear tus clases y cómo
eliminar clases antiguas esta parte es
muy importante les voy a explicar
ahorita por qué vamos a ver cómo asignar
contenido a nuestros estudiantes cuál es
el contenido no aquí en méxico qué
vídeos o sea que es un vídeo un artículo
evaluaciones hoy día ya podemos asignar
también evaluaciones
vamos a ver nuevo tablero de tareas que
está increíble les va a encantar las
nuevas características de la plataforma
y vamos a ver también esto que es nuevo
también avance de los alumnos y el
contenido de mentalidad de crecimiento
vamos a comenzar con la primera parte de
crear tus clases o eliminar clases
activas porque es importante recuerden
que cuando ustedes se registren en
campeonato automáticamente todas las
clases que ustedes han creado en khan
academy van a quedar registradas o
incorporadas a campeonato es por eso que
es muy importante que eliminemos las
clases antiguas las clases de años
anteriores las clases que ya no estamos
utilizando
porque si no las eliminamos al
inscribirnos en campeonato
automáticamente van a quedar inscritas y
obviamente bueno no van a registrar
ningún puntaje porque no estamos
trabajando con esas clases entonces lo
primero que vamos a hacer es eliminar
nuestras clases antiguas las que ya no
estamos usando y vamos a crear las
clases nuevas de este año escolar no y
al siguiente paso va a ser ya
inscribirnos en campeonato entonces cómo
vamos a hacer esto lo primero es entrar
a la plataforma ya muchos de ustedes la
conocen algunos de ustedes ya la han
usado si no la han usado si esta es la
primera vez que saben de khan academy
vamos a crear una cuenta rápidamente
juntos para que puedan ya empezar a
crear su primera clase entonces lo
primero que van a hacer es entrar a ese
punto khan academy punto org que es la
plataforma en español
para aquellos que no tienen una cuenta
que aún no tienen una cuenta les voy a
decir cuáles son los pasos sencillos
para crear la 1 vamos a entrar como les
digo a este enlace no en una ventana
pongan ese punto en academy punto org y
automáticamente se les va a abrir la
ventana de khan academy en donde ustedes
van a hacer clic en maestros inician
aquí ustedes van a entrar como maestros
el siguiente paso una vez que hacen clic
en maestro se inician aquí
automáticamente se abre una segunda
ventana en donde les dice cómo quieren
registrarse pueden registrarse con su
cuenta de google+ pueden registrarse con
facebook o pueden registrarse con su
correo electrónico aquí yo les
recomiendo siempre hacerlo con su correo
electrónico porque si por alguna razón
cierran su cuenta en facebook pues
automáticamente van a perder su
información o van a ya no van a quedar
registrados digamos en can academy
entonces les sugiero que lo hagan con
correo electrónico entonces una vez que
hacen clic en regístrate con tu correo
electrónico se abre una tercera ventana
en esta tercera ventana es muy sencillo
lo único que tiene que poner en su
correo electrónico ojo este correo
electrónico que ustedes van a usar para
registrarse es el mismo correo
electrónico que van a usar para
registrarse en cualquier cosa de khan
academy es la manera en que khan academy
puede identificarlos entonces el mismo
que usted
pongan aquí es el que van a usar para
cualquier formulario para cualquier
registro de canacar y después van a
poner su nombre de su apellido y van a
crear una contraseña con al menos 8
caracteres hagan algo
que no sea fácil digamos de copiar no
entonces créanlo con símbolos letras
mayúsculas números etcétera pero
apuntaló en algún lugar que sepan o sea
donde que lo recuerden más adelante
etcétera para que no pierdan nuevamente
su información una vez que ustedes
completan esta información ya
automáticamente se abre su cuenta crean
su cuenta y ya entran automáticamente a
su cuenta entonces una vez que ya
crearon su cuenta les voy a enseñar
ahora cómo empiezo a crear mi primera
clase
entonces maestros aquellos que no tienen
su cuenta aún sigan estos tres sencillos
pasos y en cuestión de un par de minutos
que quedan registrados no y quedan ya
dentro de canacar entonces
sigan los tres pasos vamos a esperarlos
un poquito para que puedan empezar con
nosotros a crear su primera clase
para el siguiente paso y crear clases me
voy a salir de la presentación y voy a
entrar a la plataforma en sí entonces
voy a entrar aquí
y entro a la plataforma entonces
aquellos que están creando su cuenta
como les dije van a entrar aquí en
maestro se inician aquí así de sencillo
y van a seguir los pasos que les dije
registrarse con su correo electrónico y
después poner sus datos y crear su
cuenta aquellos que ya tienen su cuenta
vamos a hacer click en iniciar sesión en
nuestro correo
ok voy a poner mi contraseña
ok inició sesión
hay algo ese mal
porque no quiere
bueno
ok perdón desorden ok entonces
para un poquito que esté un poco lento
aquí en internet y bueno entramos ya a
la cuenta como pueden ver ya tenemos
aquí el banner de inscribir para
inscribirse al campeonato no recuerden
que el campeonato empieza el 10 de
septiembre o sea ya estamos a semanas la
verdad muy poquitas semanas sin embargo
ya desde el 13 de agosto están abiertas
las inscripciones que pasase no me
inscribo antes del 10 de septiembre no
pasa nada yo me puedo inscribir aún
después de que haya comenzado campeonato
no se preocupen por esa parte entonces
aquellos que acaban de abrir su cuenta
ustedes van a entrar y obviamente no van
a tener nada acá porque esto son clases
que yo ya he creado sí y ahora como
comienzo a crear una clase es muy
sencillo lo primero que yo voy a hacer
es aquí tengo un botón abajito del
banner del lado derecho que dice agregar
una clase entonces les voy a pedir a
todos que si ya están en su cuenta
hagamos clic en agregar una clase y se
abre esta ventana
aquí son tres pasos muy sencillos para
crear una clase el primer paso es
ponerle el nombre a mi clase y aquí les
pido que sean y le sugiero que están muy
específicos no porque a veces estamos
dando diversos grupos de primero de
secundaria nosotros yo voy a poner por
ejemplo colegio
vamos a poner por un ejemplo no
americano por poner un ejemplo primero
de secundaria
vamos a ponerlo o primero secundaria veo
primero secundarias etcétera entonces
también tengo la opción aquí si yo estoy
trabajando con google classroom yo puedo
importar los resultados digamos a los
alumnos que tengan alguna clase conecta
con una cuenta de google classroom y
desde aquí la verdad es muy sencillo
seleccionan una clase de google
classroom con la que desean está la que
desean incorporar y automáticamente la
seleccionan y se importan los alumnos
que tienen en su clase de google claro
no aquí por ejemplo tengo dos selecciono
desde qué clase quiero importar a mis
alumnos y listo si no estoy trabajando
con khan academy luego perdón con el
google claro nada más pongo ingresa el
nombre de tu clase y le doy siguiente
en este segundo paso lo que voy a hacer
ahora es seleccionar qué curso voy a dar
entonces yo dije que era primero de
secundaria recuerden este y para
aquellos que no lo saben yo en can
academy no necesariamente tengo que
asignar un solo curso a la mejor yo
comienzo con primero de secundaria pero
ya por ahí de finales de año voy a
comenzar a ver algunos conceptos
etcétera de segundo de secundaria así
que yo puedo agregar diferentes cursos
puedo agregar primero de secundaria y
pre algebra por ejemplo y además de todo
una vez creada mi clase yo también puedo
editarla entonces tampoco tengo esa
preocupación de que ya lo hice ya no lo
puedo cambiar no pueden podemos también
tener biología química física ingeniería
eléctrica recuerden que campeonato es
para todos los alumnos desde primaria
hasta bachillerato y no solamente es
para matemáticas también puede ser
biología química física y bueno en el
caso de algunas escuelas que tienen esta
materia ingeniera eléctrica pueden
también incluir
no entonces yo selecciono lo primero de
secundaria y le voy a dar siguiente
y aquí viene el tercer paso que es ya
invitar a mis alumnos y aquí tengo
varias opciones nuevamente puedo hacer
puedo hacer importar desde google
classroom y aquí nuevamente puedo
seleccionar si no lo hice anteriormente
aquí lo puedo hacer y seleccionar la
clase desde la que quiero importar a mis
alumnos o bien puedo enviar una
invitación por correo electrónico a mis
alumnos o bien también otra opción que
para mí es la que más me gusta es a
través de un código de la clase todas
las clases que yo género en can academy
tienen un código específico si en este
caso este es este es el código si es x
se j 5 n 2 z m entonces qué voy a hacer
cuando tengo a todos mis alumnos juntos
si a mí es por eso que me gusta mucho y
prefiero esta opción porque teniendo los
aprovechando no cuando los tengo todos
en el salón los primeros días de clases
les voy a decir por favor vayan a khan
academy punto org diagonal join love as
escribo en el pizarrón para que los
alumnos entren ahí y aquí lo único que
van a hacer ellos a quien únete a una
clase van a pegar el código que ustedes
también van a escribir en el pizarrón y
ellos van a hacer clic en un été a la
clase fíjense como en cuestión de
segundos
ellos quedan ingresados a la clase del
profesor entonces es muy sencillo no
unirse a la clase entonces voy a
regresar aquí a mí
a mi clase
y acá estamos la clase es colegio
americano entonces yo ya tengo un
estudiante ok entonces recuerden que la
manera más importante más fácil digamos
siempre de invitar alumnos siempre va a
ser a través del código y también la
otra opción que puedo tener es la de
imprimir estas instrucciones en donde no
están no las tenemos todavía en español
está nada más en inglés pero aquí yo
puedo ponerles el código de la clase
darles un cuadrito a cada uno de mis
alumnos y que lo peguen en su cuaderno
para que puedan si por alguna razón se
salen de la clase etcétera puedan
acceder de nuevo no entonces esta es
otra opción que que tenemos pero sí les
recomiendo es la más fácil me ha pasado
que meses después dos semanas después
sigo teniendo alumnos que no se han
unido a mi clase porque no han visto su
correo entonces es la más eficiente no
hay la más efectiva utilizar el código
para invitar a nuestros alumnos una vez
que invitamos a nuestros alumnos
automáticamente
en la clase y yo ya estoy lista para
empezar a revisar el contenido de
primero de secundaria preguntas hasta
aquí
ok vamos a ver
vamos a regresar aquí a la presentación
y bueno
aquí tienen ya cómo crear una clase en
khan academy justo lo que hicimos
ahorita en la plataforma y como les
decía otra parte importante es cómo
elimino clases antiguas como les decía
anteriormente es importantísimo que
eliminen sus clases viejas no para que
no queden inscritas en automático a
campeonato cómo voy a hacer esto esto
nuevamente me voy a salir me voy a la
plataforma ok y para yo poder eliminar
mis clases fíjense qué sencillo es la
verdad es que si es muy sencillo voy a
cerrar todo esto
y me voy a ir lo que es a mi página
principal donde están todas mis clases
aquí están todas mis clases y yo lo
único que tengo que hacer es ok voy aa
seleccionar la clase que yo quiero
eliminar estos voy a seleccionar esta
clase por ejemplo hago clic en la clase
y la abro y aquí en configuración me voy
a ir a configuración estando dentro de
mi clase ya que automáticamente está el
botón eliminar esta clase le hago clic
me pregunta está seguro que quieres
eliminar la clase y le digo ok y
automáticamente la clase queda eliminada
de mi cuenta ojo estoy eliminando una
clase no estoy eliminando mi cuenta
mi cuenta sigue intacta perfecta con el
resto de mis clases yo lo único estoy
haciendo es eliminando una clase dentro
de mi cuenta no entonces vamos a hacerlo
nuevamente para que si hay alguna duda
quede más claro voy a seleccionar
primero voy a seleccionar ahorita esta
clase que acabó de crear selecciono la
clase que quiero eliminar
me voy a la configuración de mi clase
este botón aparecen todas las clases que
ustedes han creado le hago clic en
configuración y automáticamente eliminó
esta clase es cuestión la verdad de un
par de minutos entonces si desea la
tarea antes de inscribirse a campeonato
de eliminar todas las clases que ya no
están usando
ok vamos a regresar a la presentación
entonces el siguiente punto que queremos
ver es
como asigno contenido a mis estudiantes
recuerden que en campeonato lo que
nosotros como profesores tenemos que
hacer es asignar tres recursos por
semana al menos tres recursos por semana
claro que puedo asignar mucho más y creo
que terminamos asignando mucho más
porque la verdad es que los alumnos se
enganchan con la plataforma les gusta la
plataforma y podemos utilizarla con más
frecuencia pero un mínimo de tres
recursos por semana a todos mis
estudiantes ojo con esto esto es muy
importante maestros porque él lo mis
alumnos tienen que participar al 100%
porque hacemos esto porque este
requisito porque sabemos todos no todos
somos docentes que hay algunos alumnos
que son súper responsables que siempre
participan que siempre entregan todo
pero también tenemos algunos que da
mejores cuesta un poco más de trabajo
que hay que empujarlos un poquito más
etcétera entonces es por esto que que
nosotros tratamos de motivar a aquellos
alumnos que generalmente no participan o
que les cuesta participar para que se
comprometan porque el éxito de la
requiere de la participación de todos
los alumnos si por ejemplo no había dado
el ejemplo anteriormente de si tengo
digamos 15 alumnos y voy a enseñar voy a
dar tres o tres recursos para cada uno
bueno esto significa que tengo 45
actividades que tengo que que deben
entregar y solamente cuando se han hecho
en las 45 actividades registradas se
registran las 45 la clase alcanza el
100% en ese nivel recuerden que son
diferentes niveles dentro del campeonato
entonces sí es muy importante que todos
participen entonces aquí vamos a ver
cómo asigno esos tres recursos y cuáles
son esos recursos a los que yo tengo
acceso entonces pueden ser vídeos
recuerden que khan academy no nada más
se trata de vídeos mucha gente piensa
que campeonat que perdón que cada
academy son vídeos y no hoy día hay
muchos recursos más te contamos con
vídeos con artículos o ejercicios
obviamente y hoy día también podemos
asignar hasta el baló
o exámenes de unidad que eso es nuevo y
bueno vino a nadar a añadir perdón
muchísimo valor a la plataforma y sobre
todo nos viene también a facilitar
muchísimo a nosotros nuestro trabajo
entonces vamos a ver cómo asignamos ese
contenido debo regresar nuevamente a la
plataforma
ok y aquí voy a seleccionar una de mis
clases que ya tengo creadas a ver
cualquiera de las que ya tengo tengo una
vamos a seleccionar esta depresión ok
entonces fíjense lo que yo voy a hacer
yo entro a mi clase cuando ya la tengo
creada siempre que yo haga clic en
contenido
voy a tener acceso a todos los conceptos
no y todas las habilidades que mi alumno
debe aprender en este curso que yo
seleccione en este caso de esta clase de
este ejemplo yo seleccione pre algebra
recuerden que yo siempre puedo cambiarlo
si yo me voy a configuración y le digo
aquí quiero cambiar el curso
automáticamente se me abre esto yo puedo
seleccionar ok lo quiero cambiar quiero
que sea primero de secundaria o quiero
que sea segundo de secundaria según sea
el caso no entonces siempre existe esa
opción de cambiar o de agregar otro
curso no vamos a ponerle agregar vamos a
agregar en este caso dos cursos entonces
aquí cuando yo regreso al contenido yo
aquí voy a tener ok de qué curso estamos
hablando quieres el contenido de pre
algebra o quieres
de fundamentos de álgebra porque lo
acabo de agregar todos vamos a ver el de
pre álgebra yo digo que es las primeras
semanas de clase y vamos estamos viendo
propiedades aritméticas no todos hago
clic y automáticamente al hacer clic en
este tema en esta unidad yo aquí veo
diferentes a pues unidades diferentes
conceptos que mis alumnos tienen que
aprender no estoy o puede ser lo que el
valor posicional
si hago clic dentro de ese concepto
miren todos los recursos a los que yo
tengo acceso recuerde nuevamente que
pueden ser ejercicios pueden ser vídeos
no no sé si aquí en esta tengo a pueda
tener algún artículo aquí tengo un
artículo y fíjense acá más adelante
tengo un cuestionario un cuestionario
esto viene siendo una pequeña evaluación
que hace esa evaluación lo que hace es
le manda al alumno
diferentes ejercicios de diferentes
conceptos que ha practicado ya no se
concentra en uno solo sino que dice de
aquí te voy a mandar como ya has
practicado todo esto te voy a mandar
ejercicios de valor posición
de cómo redondear números naturales y
cómo reagruparnos de los naturales al
contestar estos cuestionarios los
alumnos avanzan de nivel realmente está
ahí cuando ganan más puntos y avanzan de
nivel entonces como asigno yo lo que
quiero a mandar a mis alumnos lo primero
que yo voy a hacer y esto es parte es
importante porque necesitamos ser
empáticos con nuestros alumnos y
necesitamos también percibir no cómo es
que ellos están viendo la plataforma
entonces vamos a ver que yo tengo aquí
este vídeo no encontrar el valor
posicional y es un vídeo y yo quiero
primero antes de asignarlo quiero ver
cómo lo va a percibir el alumno
hago clic en vista previa incluso puedo
hacer clic en cómo lo va a ver el alumno
vista del alumno y aquí me aparece cómo
lo va a ver el alumno y yo puedo hasta
ver el género automático para su mente a
mi en lo personal me gusta expander los
valores de esta cantidad los alumnos los
vídeos verdaderamente son sencillos son
fáciles de entender son cortos porque si
ponemos algo muy no demasiado largo para
nuestro
alumnos sabemos que no lo van a ver
entonces me gusta el vídeo ya vi ya hice
clic en vista previa lo vi estoy de
acuerdo y luego voy a hacer clic digo
bueno que ya que hay un ejercicio siete
preguntas a ver de qué se trata este
ejercicio hago clic en vista
previa y aquí fíjense bien me dice los
estudiantes harán siete de estas 20
preguntas o sea hay 20 preguntas de este
concepto mis alumnos van a recibir 7 le
hago clic en vista del alumno y aquí voy
a ver cómo va a ver el alumno esas siete
preguntas fíjense que acá abajo dicen
siete problemas a medida que el alumno
va contestando las preguntas mira vamos
a hacerlos así bueno no sé si me lo
permite vamos a ver por ejemplo no
representa un valor de 90 entonces cuál
sería vamos a ponerle aquí
ok y el alumno siempre va recibiendo
retroalimentación si a mí me gusta le
digo que es adecuado para mis alumnos le
voy a hacer clic en asignar fíjense como
automáticamente yo al seleccionar los
recursos tienes este botoncito acá
arriba ya me dice estás asignando los
recursos recuerden pero para que para
campeonato
necesito asignar tres recursos por como
mínimo cada semana os voy a asignar otro
otro recurso me voy a ir para abajo digo
ok aquí hay otro de escribir números
naturales en notación extendida ve otra
vez
el ejercicio cómo se escribe o que me
gusta van a recibir 7 de 15 diferentes
preguntas que hay te digo que hay me
parece muy bien voy a nuevamente a ver
cómo lo van a percibir mis alumnos
ok cómo se escribe esto entonces les
vamos a cometer un error aquí vamos a
poner
que no vamos a equivocarnos y fíjense lo
que el alumno recibe en caso de
equivocarse todavía no del todo
inténtalo de nuevo y siempre resto
alumno va a tener oportunidad de recibir
ayuda esto viene siendo como un tutor
personal para ellos cuando nosotros no
estamos presentes no entonces aquí ellos
pueden o no recurrir a un vídeo si así
es que están teniendo problemas o
recurrir también a tips no a claves como
para resolver ese problema entonces una
vez que vean el vídeo o ven uno o
reciben estos estas claves dice ok
entonces la respuesta puede ser esta y
entonces siempre reciben esta
retroalimentación positiva no mantén tu
empeño excelente trabajo continúa y esta
parte a mí me encanta porque de verdad
motiva a los alumnos de verdad es es un
factor que cambia la perspectiva de los
alumnos con respecto a matemáticas ya
ciencias no entonces veo esto agregó me
gusta voy a asignarlo a mis alumnos y lo
selección aquí ya me parece que esto ya
signan 23 y yo puedo decir incluso digo
ok ya los mis alumnos practicaron todo
esto podría aquí vamos a vernos para
atrás voy a asignar el cuestionario ok
entonces aquí estoy asignando 4 incluso
me estoy pasando en un honor y a la
verdad yo seleccionado ya tengo aquí
asignar 4 cuando estoy lista o listo
lavo clic en la asignar y se abre esta
ventana y me dice estás asignando cuatro
elementos a tu clase ok
aquí fíjense esto también es algo nuevo
y me parece que bueno genial y
maravilloso que lo hayan agregado porque
nosotros podemos querer que cada
estudiante trabaje en un conjunto
aleatorio de preguntas qué quiere decir
esto que los alumnos cada uno en sus
alumnos a recibir diferentes tipos de
preguntas dentro de las 20 opciones cada
uno va a recibir siete ejercicios
diferentes con esto evitamos que copien
con esto evitamos que uno conteste la
tarea del otro etcétera no sé no del
todo porque sabemos que siempre se las
ingenian
y lo hace un poquito más complicado o
bien si nosotros queremos uniformar
podemos decir lo que quiero que todos
mis estudiantes trabajen en el mismo
conjunto de preguntas
esta opción se las dejamos a ustedes
docentes no acá fíjense aquí qué fácil
es yo aquí puedo hacer clic en clase y
si yo tengo diferentes clases en donde
estoy enseñando pre algebra a lo mejor
estoy enseñando pre algebra en segundo
de secundaria abc no entonces yo desde
aquí puedo seleccionar a todas las
clases a las que les quiero asignar
estos recursos entonces no lo tengo que
hacer de una por una esto me ahorra
muchísimo tiempo y también aquí esta
parte de los estudiantes no recuerden
que siendo campeonato yo se los tengo
que seleccionar a todos a todos luego de
otra manera no van a llegar al 100%
entonces aquí yo voy a decir seleccionar
y mandarlo a todos
sin embargo cuando campeona de
campeonato termine en noviembre la
plataforma va a volver a su función
y aquí recuerdan también que ustedes
pueden seleccionar a qué alumnos en
específico se lo quieren mandar y esto
nos ayuda muchísimo como docentes a
poder diferenciar no para poder
realmente personalizar la enseñanza y si
yo sé que diego y dado que están
teniendo problemas con estos conceptos
no necesariamente el toque mandato a mi
clase porque a lo mejor tus alumnos ya
lo superaron
ya lo aprendieron pero se lo va a mandar
en específico a eso con un clic estoy
realmente diferenciando realmente
atendiendo las necesidades personales de
cada uno mis alumnos no tosco como
estamos hablando de campeonato yo voy a
seleccionar a todos y automáticamente
hago clic en asignar estos cuatro
elementos entonces hago clic en asignar
y automáticamente si yo me voy a mis
tareas ahí van a aparecer las les voy a
explicar el nuevo tablero de tareas pero
al hacer clic en tareas fíjense la
maravilla de este tablero que esto es
nuevo totalmente nuevo y que me dice
este tablero aquí esto no existe antes y
nos hace trabajo también mucho más fácil
para nosotros porque tiene va a estar
poniendo los nombres de todos mis
alumnos y las diferentes tareas que yo
les he mandado aquí ya podemos ver las
tareas que acabo de agregar ok y aquí a
medida que ellos van contestando aquí me
va a ir diciendo solamente si son
ejercicios obvio porque es un vídeo o un
artículo no se puede calificar pero aquí
me va a ir diciendo la calificación de
cada uno de mis alumnos no en esta tarea
en específico entonces ya desde aquí ya
me dice no sabe por ejemplo finance ha
contestado en la mayor parte de sus
tareas no va muy bien etcétera y depende
quiero que pasó aquí hago clic
y me da la opción de entrar
reporte este reporte para nosotros es
valiosísimo porque primero que nada es
en tiempo real en nos anteriormente que
cómo funciona esto de las tareas que les
damos la tarea al siguiente día o la
siguiente clase la regresan me la llevo
yo a casa la calificó y a lo mejor 34
clases después si es que tengo mucho
trabajo los chicos vienen recibiendo su
tarea y recibiendo la retroalimentación
con khan academy esto es en tiempo real
ellos están contestando la tarea en su
casa y yo automáticamente estoy viendo
los resultados en la mía no entonces yo
puedo revisar aquí en tarea es decir ya
contestar la tarea a ver qué pasó con
nancy no los voy a entregar al reporte
voy a decir ok
nancy tuvo mal estas preguntas no tuvo
2 una pregunta mal de 4 entonces yo al
siguiente día aquellos alumnos que a lo
mejor se sacaban más de 80 los voy a
agrupar para darles una actividad a lo
mejor es más difícil o que sigan
practicando tan academy etcétera y
aquellos alumnos que les costó ese
ejercicio me los voy a calar voy a hacer
un grupo más pequeño y voy a enseñar el
concepto de esta manera imagínense qué
fácil puedo realmente no como les vuelvo
a decir a atender las necesidades en el
momento de mis alumnos porque si yo
ignoro esto qué va a pasar con la asigna
si va a ir acumulando sus dudas y va muy
bien pero a medida que siga acumulando
sus dudas y sus dudas de sus dudas va a
llegar una unidad más adelante en donde
nancy ya repruebe matemáticas o esté de
plano y pasándola mal es frustrada
desmotivada porque dejamos que este
concepto no lo entendiera bien no
entonces va acumulando no está estas
faltas hasta que llegó un punto en que
la materia se re complica porque sabemos
en matemáticas sobre todo el aprendizaje
no es constructivo entonces si los
alumnos se atoran en fracciones
obviamente no van a poder resolver
ecuaciones con fracciones entonces esto
me permite a mí como les digo atender no
esos a estas dificultades de mis alumnos
desde un principio en hoy y mandarles a
lo mejor a ellos no más práctica
etcétera hasta que lleguen a dominar el
concepto entonces este tablero la manera
en que lo están presentando ahorita la
verdad está súper mal porque a mí como
docente me da muchísima información otra
manera en que aparece es que si yo le
hago clic aquí en lugar de por alumno
por tarea
me abre aquí la tarea y aquí si se fijan
tengo todas las tareas que yo he dado a
ese grupo me dice la fecha en que ésta
tiene que ser entregada la tarea hasta
cuándo tiene que estar entregada cuando
se asignó quienes las han completado
aquí nadie la ha completado sin embargo
aquí hay uno de 30 con uno que conteste
automáticamente se activa este botón que
dice ver reporte y me va a permitir
también ver el mismo reporte que vi en
la sección de por alumno ok ahora le voy
a regresar acá y voy a regresar a
contenido qué pasa si yo tengo y nos
sucede que a veces tenemos un poquito de
tiempo extra digo que voy a planear mis
clases de que voy a tener en dos semanas
o ahorita tengo tiempo voy a planear mis
actividades de campeonato no mis
siguientes 10 actividades de campeonato
entonces yo me voy a contenido y vamos a
suponer que yo digo ok en unas dos
semanas yo voy a estar viendo orden de
operaciones
ok entonces veo orden de operaciones
nuevamente esto es un vídeo puedo ver el
vídeo me gusta lo que veo está muy claro
es justamente lo que yo voy a dar en
clase lo seleccionó si se prende el
botón y me está diciendo estás asignando
uno como es un tema dijo quiero asignar
tres para esta semana ok voy a decir voy
a ver asignar este nuevamente puedo ver
ok
perfecto esto es lo que yo quiero está
ajusta perfecto al nivel que van a estar
este que van a ver ellos y puedo incluso
decir ok
también les voy a asignar un
cuestionario van a recibir cinco
preguntas ok ya tengo el botón de
asignar test le voy a hacer clic les voy
a hacer aquí antes de asignarlo para que
vean cómo se ve una prueba de unidad si
yo lo voy y arc y clic en ver vista del
estudiante esto es lo que el alumno va a
recibir le va a decir ok si tú contestas
bien estas cinco bueno estas preguntas
nos vas a subir de nivel en 12
habilidades porque aquí va a recibir
preguntas sobre todos estos diferentes
temas nosotros va a recibir 11 preguntas
no de estos diferentes temas entonces
aquí dicen empezar prueba de unidad y es
una manera si nosotros queremos hacer
una prueba en nuestra clase esto nos
sirve excelente como un repaso a lo
mejor no como una
este no sé si como digamos un repaso
algo para que los chicos puedan
practicar antes de que nosotros en clase
presentemos un examen y automáticamente
van a subir de nivel acuérdense que en
khan academia de diferentes niveles
desde practicado hasta que dominan el
concepto y entonces aquellos van van a
llegar sea si lo contesta si toma la
prueba de unidad para llegar a dominio y
vas a obtener 910 puntos 2 en que te van
a decir que ya domina este estos
conceptos entonces estas estas son las
pruebas digamos esto yo ya tengo así que
voy a asignar estos tres recursos hago
clic en asignar pero recuerden que esto
yo lo voy a ver en unas dos semanas esto
yo digo ok
quiero que nuevamente cada estudiante
trabaje aleatorio en ejercicios
aleatorios selecciono mi clase selección
a todos los estudiantes recuerden que yo
le puedo poner una fecha límite como yo
estoy hablando de que esto lo voy a ver
hasta dentro de tres semanas voy a poner
que quiero que esto esté listo
para el 6 de septiembre más o menos
puedo incluso poner la hora se mi clase
es a las 11 de la mañana voy a poner
quiero que esto esté listo a las 11 am y
le voy a dar no asignar porque yo no lo
quiero asignar ahorita yo lo quiero
guardar para asignar más tarde qué va a
pasar con estos tres recursos si yo me
voy a tareas
y me voy ahora aportaría a quinta el
portar ya veo activa y guardada si yo le
doy clic en guardada aquí
automáticamente aparecen todas las
tareas que yo tengo guardadas cuando
llega el momento que ya estoy lista para
asignar las lo único que yo tengo que
hacer es ok estoy lista la voy asignar
ok entonces
hago clic en el perdón está ya se venció
pero vamos por acá
ok voy a asignar ok y automáticamente se
asigna y se pasa a tareas no que están
activas recuerden que tienen que asignar
las tres para que cuenten dentro del
campeonato entonces esa es la manera de
asignar tareas y es la manera de poder
ver en el nuevo tablero de tareas como
no como perseo sa como puedo percibir yo
el desempeño de mis alumnos cada uno de
mis alumnos en cada una de las tareas
que yo enviado y cómo puedo también no
ir viendo en las tareas cuántas tareas
se ha agregado en qué fecha quienes ya
la completaron quienes no etcétera
entonces esta información para nosotros
como nosotros como docentes no es
realmente es muy valiosa y como les digo
a mí la parte más importante es que es
un tiempo real
preguntas hasta aquí leonor
no no no
con respecto al campeonato me imaginé
que algunos de ustedes ya están
enterados de que estamos lanzando un
reto para el regreso a clases y una de
las preguntas que están haciendo los
profesores es que si todo el contenido
que tienen que asignar cuenta para
campeonatos el campeonato es un reto
específico que empieza el 10 de
septiembre y termina en noviembre y
durante todo ese tiempo que ustedes esté
bueno si es que se quieren inscribir en
este reto todo el contenido que ustedes
asignen va a contar como puntos para su
clase y si no desean participar en el
reto pues lo que van a tener es una
plataforma completamente distinta
visualmente en la cual ustedes pueden
seguir avanzando con sus artículos pero
si esa era la pregunta que si todo lo
que asignaban los profesores a su clase
contaba como puntos para el reto no hay
para el premio entonces es comparto esa
duda en caso
de que algunos de ustedes la tenga
porque me imagino que algunos de ustedes
ya están enterados de esta campaña y
este programa que estamos lanzando en
septiembre claro siempre y cuando
obviamente ustedes se inscriban en
campeonato si ustedes no se inscriben en
campeonato ustedes van a tener acceso a
la plataforma normal no si ustedes se
inscriben el campeonato todo lo que
hagan en khan academy cuenta
ok vamos a entonces hablemos ahorita
como percibe el alumno el vídeo los
artículos las evaluaciones los
ejercicios como les digo esto de verdad
añade muchísimo valor a la plataforma yo
de verdad que estoy muy agradecida con
khan academy por todos los cambios
positivos que ha hecho que no que
definitivamente nos vienen a hacer o no
vienen a hacer nuestro trabajo mucho más
sencillo y mucho más eficiente entonces
vamos a continuar bueno ya vimos lo del
nuevo tablero no de tareas
recuerden que todas estas son las
diferentes asignaturas o cursos que yo
puedo añadir en la plataforma de español
de khan academy como les digo puede ser
por matemáticas o sea por tema de
matemáticas por grado o también algunas
ciencias
y esto lo que les comentaba en la
plataforma estos son ustedes pueden
asignar vídeos ustedes pueden asignar
artículos que son muy interesantes super
sencillos de entender no muy fáciles de
comprender pueden que los alumnos a
pueden guardar recursos también pueden
ser ejercicios como les decía o también
pueden ser cuestionarios y pruebas de
unidad los cuestionarios son más chicos
no generalmente vienen 5 preguntas no de
menos temas de menos conceptos cuando ya
es una prueba de unidad tienen 16
preguntas o sea ya son algo más grande y
vienen ya de varios temas no de una
unidad consta
supongamos de seis conceptos pues les
van a venir preguntas de los seis
conceptos que conforman esta unidad no
entonces estos son los diferentes
recursos que ustedes pueden agregar
recuerda aquí también en la presentación
les estoy poniendo también los
diferentes pasos que deben seguir para
poder asignar tareas a su clase para que
lo tengan siempre a la mano y recuerden
que siempre que pueden tener tareas
activas pueden tener tareas guardadas
esa parte también nos facilita el
trabajo entonces
vamos a ver ahora esto es el reporte que
ustedes al que tienen acceso y vamos a
ver ahora las nuevas características de
la plataforma esta parte que les voy a
contar ahorita la verdad también bueno
me emociona muchísimo cuando lo visto
esto es muy nuevo es muy muy nuevo y
créanme que como maestra de matemáticas
y de ciencias lo que a veces realmente
nos sentimos frustrados por no tener
tanto tiempo no para hacer lo que más
nos gusta que es enseñar no a veces
estamos demasiado metidos en reportes en
calificaciones en cuestiones
administrativas no entonces aquí esta
parte nos hace el trabajo mucho más
efectivo nos permite ahorrar tiempo
enfocarnos
realmente cosas a veces hasta más
importantes entonces lo voy a compartir
con ustedes para esto nuevamente me voy
a salir de la presentación para entrar a
la plataforma
vamos a cerrar todas estas que no
necesitamos ahorita
y vamos a entrar a la plataforma ok
entonces yo estoy aquí en la plataforma
estoy en mi clase
en todas las clases que ustedes están
vayan a crear hoy hayan creado les va a
aparecer este menú de contenido tareas
avance actividad lista y configuración
ya vimos contenido tenemos tareas vimos
que en configuras ustedes pueden
configurar su clase cambiar el nombre
cambiar el curso etcétera no y ahora
vamos a ver esta ventana o este perdón
opción en el menú que es avance esta
parte también fue reformada en su
totalidad cambió muchísimo y la verdad
es que la manera en que lo están
planteando ahora es mucho más clara y
nos da todavía más información de la que
nos daba ahora así que la forma anterior
no entonces fíjense aquí yo hago clic en
avance y aquí me da varias opciones aquí
me está diciendo que por alumno
yo estoy comenzando el año escolar
entonces solamente la mayoría de mis
alumnos están en cero en el 0 por ciento
de del curso el curso es pre álgebra y
fíjense aquí
este es mi curso que voy a dar este año
para que los alumnos lleguen a completar
el 100% del curso necesitan acumular 25
mil 750 puntos cuando los alumnos
lleguen a esta cantidad de productos van
a aparecer aquí y aquí va a estar la
gráfica con los alumnos que están en
este porcentaje como logran los alumnos
de este porcentaje practicando
practicando las diferentes diferentes
conceptos y las diferentes habilidades
que ellos tienen que aprender dentro del
curso de pre algebra entonces si es el
principio de año si son las primeras
semanas de clase obvio que aquí pues la
mayoría de mis alumnos están aquí no en
el 0% algunos a lo mejor han cubierto no
sé un 2% un 1% un 5% cuál es mi objetivo
como maestro siempre motivarlos eso
maestros es súper importante que
reconozcamos su esfuerzo récord es que
reconozcamos sus logros y siempre los
estemos motiva motivando para que vayan
muy bien
a través de estas de esta gráfica hasta
llegar al 100% a los 25 mil 750 puntos
que necesitan para haber cubierto el
curso de pre álgebra
entonces aquí yo puedo ver si hago clic
me dice en este nivel tienes a 30
estudiantes a medida que ellos vayan
avanzando obviamente aquí van a aparecer
otras gráficas si yo le hago clic en
vamos a poner 40 por ciento va a decir
aquí tienes 20 estudiantes o 10
estudiantes entonces esto va a ir
cambiando a medida que va progresando el
año escolar ok ahora esto es el curso en
general aquí me da la información de en
tu curso de pre algebra en qué
porcentaje qué porcentaje han cubierto
cada uno de estos alumnos si yo me voy
un poquito más abajo aquí hablamos ya de
unidades de todas las unidades que tiene
mi curso de pre algebra que estamos
hablando que dentro de para algebra
tengo 10 unidades que los alumnos tienen
que cubrir
las propiedades aritméticas lee la
siguiente leer e interpretar datos
fracciones números negativos ecuaciones
etcétera exponentes razones decimales
medición factores entonces mis alumnos
tienen que cubrir en su totalidad todas
estas unidades para poder alcanzar el
100% o cumplir con el 100% del curso de
presión sin embargo aquí en esta parte
aquí me va a decir por unidad donde está
cada uno de mis alumnos y esta
información es nueva es fresca esto no
existía antes y es increíble porque aquí
me dice ok en este pequeño porcentaje a
esta pequeña gráfica que yo tengo aquí
si me dice tienes aquí un estudiante ok
que me dice 15 o sea aquí de todas estas
habilidades que tienen que aprender
dentro de esta unidad ok
hay 29 de tus alumnos que ni siquiera
han comenzado con introducción al valor
posicional hay alumnos que ya uno está
éstos son los diferentes niveles
los alumnos empiezan con x
cuando no han empezado pues aparecen acá
cuando empiezan pero sacan menos del 70%
en sus tareas etcétera aquí les va a
aparecer se ya comenzó pero está con
dificultades y para nosotros eso es una
alarma no una luz roja que yo tengo un
alumno que en orden de operaciones está
teniendo problemas yo me voy a calar
este alumno quiero que vamos a seguir
practicando le voy a enseñar el concepto
etcétera
aquí me saque de con dificultades a
medida que el alumno va practicando va
subiendo de nivel desde familiar a
competente hasta que aparece como
dominado cuándo va a llegar a esto
cuando el alumno conteste su examen de
unidad cuando conteste su cuestionario
etcétera en donde le van a hacer
preguntas diferentes temas y es aquí
cuando realmente pueden dar grandes
saltos de un nivel a otro pero aquí me
dice por unidad
no por unidad cada uno y dentro de la
unidad cada uno de los conceptos que
pertenecen a esta unidad en donde está
cada uno de mis alumnos dentro de los
conceptos de cada unidad si yo lo hago
clic a esta unidad de factores múltiples
nuevamente me abre todos los conceptos
que mis alumnos tienen que aprender
dentro de 12 de s de esa unidad esto
nuevamente aquí puedo ver quiénes están
en familia a medida que lo que avanza el
año escolar obviamente yo ya quiero ver
a mis alumnos no aquí él no ha empezado
si no los voy a ver a lo mejor algunos
son con dificultades y me enfocaré en
estos que a lo mejor algunos ya van
avanzando a familiar competente hasta
que lo dominan no entonces esta
información nuevamente para nosotros
como docentes realmente no sé es que es
muy difícil yo lo entiendo porque yo he
sido docente yo tengo no he llegado a
tener 150 alumnos es imposible que
podamos saber en dónde está exactamente
cada uno de nuestros alumnos sin embargo
esta manera en que nos están presentando
aquí
estos reportes khan academy si me
permite ver dónde está cada uno de mis
alumnos aunque en que tengo en que puedo
ayudar a uno de mis alumnos lo que tengo
que hacer para atender las necesidades
de mis alumnos sobre todo los que están
teniendo dificultades
preguntas hasta aquí
ok
entonces esta es la parte de avance que
es totalmente nueva si yo hago clic aquí
a la página antigua de avance esto es lo
que yo tenía antes no antes
pero también me da información valiosa
me daba me pone aquí todos los conceptos
yo le hacía clic y aquí veía en una
barra no que alumnos ya lo practicaron
que alumno está en práctica pero creo
que la manera en que no los están
presentando ahorita es mucho más fácil
de acceder mucho más clara para nosotros
no y además ya nos está hablando por
unidades no entonces eso también lo hace
más sencillo qué pasa si yo hago clic
aquí en actividad cuando él yo hago clic
en la actividad aquí me dice ok tienes
más o menos julio ha practicado un total
de 7 minutos él ha practicado estas
diferentes habilidades aquí me dice si
práctico durante las horas de escuela o
se practicó fuera de las horas de
escuela entonces si yo les digo me pongo
con objetivo a los alumnos les pongo
como objetivo que quiero que practiquen
semanalmente 30 minutos que es más o
menos el tiempo que requieren para
completar los tres recursos de
campeonato aquí voy a ver quién lo está
haciendo y quién no quién realmente está
no invirtiendo 30 minutos en can academy
cada semana entonces aquí esto me
permite darle un mejor seguimiento
también a cada uno de mis alumnos no
poder ver dónde está cada uno y no hay
poder también a lo mejor llamar a
aquellos alumnos que no están cumpliendo
con ese tiempo en motivarlos a encontrar
maneras no para
y reforzarlos y para empujarlos
motivarlos a que pongan un poco más de
esfuerzo recuerden que esta parte de la
motivación y del reconocimiento es vital
así que de verdad los invitamos no a que
generen un plan o plan de acción que voy
a hacer para motivar a mis alumnos qué
voy a hacer para reconocer sus logros y
aveces de verdad que hasta un aplauso
una palmada en el hombro que se levanten
y darle no va a ser un reconocimiento
público
o en la ceremonia no sé de la bandera o
de lo que todos tenemos en nuestras
diferencias planteles algún tipo de
ceremonia escolar y reconocerlos yo creo
que eso de verdad les les levante el
espíritu y les da el esfuerzo y la y la
motivación para seguir adelante entonces
esa parte no lo olviden es muy
importante
preguntas hasta aquí
leonor
están preguntando sobre los puntos de
campeonato y ya les contesté a los
maestros diciéndoles que el punto aquí
es que mínimo asigne el tres o cuatro
tareas a cada alumno
eso equivale como dices tú a 25 30
minutos que pasa del alumno por tarea lo
cual equivale como unos 60-70 minutos
por semana que si lo consideras en la
semana pues no es tanto no entonces eso
es lo mínimo que aconsejamos obviamente
con todo el material que les ha
presentado para ti pues ustedes pueden
presentar una clase completamente
diversa completamente completa entonces
tenemos artículos vídeos estos tests que
vieron entonces no tienen que asignar
siempre el mismo contenido eso es lo que
lo hace diferente
no es nuestro consejo que ustedes le
echen un ojo a cada materia y vean
los diferentes años o qué contenido le
sirve y lo vayan asignando sus
estudiantes ya sea como tarea o ahí
mismo en clase también lo pueden hacer y
con eso con eso básico que cada alumno
haga por lo menos tres cosas diferentes
o tres actividades diferentes ya cumple
con el requisito semanal sí exacto
es eso lo que tienen que tener muy en
cuenta que son mínimo de tres y yo les
puedo asegurar que así que van a estar
asignando hasta más no porque de verdad
que yo lo he visto no lo he
experimentado como los alumnos se
enganchan con la plataforma les gusta
porque poner a su propio paso a su
propio ritmo no van ganando seguridad
van ganando confianza no en las
matemáticas se van sintiendo más seguros
les va gustando entonces terminan a
veces practicando más entonces yo les
les aseguro que tres actividades no van
a ser demasiadas no les va a tomar un
tiempo de 30 minutos a la semana que
viene sino un poco entonces
todo lo que ustedes se hagan si están
inscritos en campeonato todo lo que
ustedes hagan cuenta no entonces aman en
todo lo que ustedes consideren que va a
reforzar no los conceptos enseñados en
clase ustedes envíen celo no sé es un
vídeo si es un artículo si es un
ejercicio si es un quiz si es un
una evaluación una prueba etcétera todo
todo cuenta no todo vale ahora sí
recuerden por favor y esta parte es
importante que para participar que para
que sus clases participen en campeonato
deben tener un mínimo de 10 alumnos si
ustedes tienen una clase con 5 no va a
participar esta parte es muy importante
por favor entonces aquí el punto para ti
y los así pueden participar van a
encontrar el contenido se inscriba a
nivel en control aplauden pero lo que no
van a poder ganar son los premios por
ejemplo vamos durante el campeonato
vamos a rifar unas cajas de premios para
las clases no y pues obviamente un
profesor que tiene pues 30 alumnos este
y asignó esos treinta alumnos tareas y
todos le echaron ganas pues no es lo
mismo o sea es el mismo esfuerzo si
sentimos que es un profesor que tienen
pocos alumnos también está haciendo un
esfuerzo pero no era justo entonces por
eso estamos diciendo qué
por lo menos tengan diez alumnos claro
es muy buena aclaración
ok dentro del campeonato tenemos lo que
le llamamos las actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento para mí estas
actividades
bueno he estado revisando las estado
viéndolas y están y son súper
enriquecedoras estas actividades no no
son de matemáticas no son de ciencias
estas actividades están realizadas o
están pensadas para desarrollar la mente
de nuestros alumnos sabemos que nuestros
alumnos no en ocasiones no todos pero
sobre todo en estas materias no están
muy orientados al fracaso no ya están a
veces hasta predispuestos a fracasar y
cada fracaso los desmotiva lo no los
hace como desconfiar en sí mismos
entonces todas estas actividad
actividades están hechas con el objetivo
de que el alumno vaya desarrollando una
mente más fuerte una mente más sólida y
más digámoslo así resistente al fracaso
no una una mente es que unos alumnos que
puedan realmente desarrollar estrategias
de aprendiz
reconocer su cerebro cuando funciona su
cerebro cuando pueden aprender mejor lo
cómo pueden desarrollar estrategias para
tener éxito cómo pueden convertir los
errores en oportunidades y no en
fracasos no y esa parte es vital no como
desarrollar la resiliencia desarrollar
el no el vencer la frustración para
siempre tener la mira hacia adelante y
no quedarnos no empantanados digamos en
ese fracaso ya este fracaso nos va a
seguir durante todo el año escolar
entonces estas actividades son vitales y
los maestros deben asignar estas
actividades actividades de mentalidad de
crecimiento durante campeonato
esta es bueno como les comentaba a estas
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
son han sido desarrolladas por pérez que
es un centro de estudios de stanford a
partir de investigaciones de carol dweck
entonces como les digo están
desarrolladas y están creadas y pensadas
para que los alumnos aprendan no a
convertir los errores en oportunidades
de aprendizaje para que superen la
frustración no y puedan ir desarrollando
según su cerebro según sus habilidades
estrategias para aprender mejor aquí lo
que estamos fomentando es que el alumno
se haga responsable de su propio
aprendizaje
hoy me gustaría compartir algo con los
maestros que nos están adelante invitada
y los que nos vayan a escuchar después
para los que no conozcan a carol dweck
ella es una profesora y también
investigadora de stanford ella es
psicóloga y ella se ha dedicado a
estudiar el cerebro humano y lo que se
dio cuenta es que el cerebro es
maleable o sea que decir que está sobre
todo cuando somos jóvenes cree ese y se
expande con las conexiones neuronales
entonces éste hizo una investigación muy
interesante sobre cómo nuestra
mentalidad afecta el crecimiento de
nuestro cerebro y lo que queremos con
estas actividades ya seas un profesor de
historia de literatura o de matemáticas
que puedas utilizar estas actividades
también para que tus alumnos entiendan
un poco cómo es su cerebro y cómo estas
mentalidades que tenemos o percepciones
que tenemos sobre nosotros mismos y
nuestro aprendizaje afectan muchísimo
nuestra manera de estudiar entonces
hemos decir realizarlo toda una serie de
casos de estudios de lecciones para los
profesores y guías para que ellos puedan
trabajar durante el campeonato en este
material
entonces los invitamos a que participen
se inscriban y utilicen este contenido
ahorita si se meten al sitio del
campeonato
hay una pusimos una guía en la
de recursos que la pueden ver porque hay
un material específico para los
profesores de primaria y secundaria y
otros de este material para los
estudiantes de bachillerato que ahorita
ahorita lo entramos para que lo vean ya
a quien aquí en el en la misma
presentación en 3 gracias a dorita qué
bueno que nos aporta sexto
porque si es muy importante que los
alumnos no solamente nosotros como
maestros plantear objetivos a nuestros
alumnos sabemos lo importante como
adultos sabemos lo importante que son
los objetivos no el plantearnos
objetivos y también así como nosotros se
los planteamos a ellos y es
importantísimo no dentro de nuestro plan
de reconocimiento y de motivación es
importantísimo tener objetivos claros y
plantear solos a los alumnos en el caso
del campeonato es que cada uno complete
las actividades que el docente le manda
por semana ok ahora sin embargo también
es muy importante que ellos mismos no se
plantean metas no y se mentalicen para
lograrlas y para tener éxito también hay
actividades básicamente para
bachillerato para enfrentar lo
inesperado y para tener un sentido de
pertenencia a mí algo que me encanta de
este programa de campeonato es que
estamos comenzando el pie derecho con el
pie derecho el año escolar no por qué
porque desde un principio estamos
dándole al alumno un sentido de
pertenencia
estamos trabajando en equipo juntos por
un logro no entonces eso es no super
enriquecedor porque automáticamente la
relación con ustedes docentes no se va a
ver muy beneficiada porque se van a
sentir parte de un equipo parte de un
logro común y también eso nos une más a
ellos no entonces creo que este programa
no solamente viene la parte del
beneficio de motivación y del
aprendizaje de las matemáticas sino
también va a generar y va a crear una
relación muy positiva de ustedes con sus
alumnos
este es el contenido de mentalidad de
crecimiento si usted es la sele pueden
hacer clic en la en la
digamos en la liga y van a entrar
automáticamente a las actividades este
es un ejemplo más o menos de las
actividades no de viene por lecciones y
cada lección tiene diferentes
actividades no la verdad acerca de tu
cerebro en la mentalidad de crecimiento
errores como pieza de un rompecabezas
etcétera no entonces ya con más calma
ustedes pueden entrar y ver para qué
realmente están testigos de la pues de
la nueva oportunidad que tenemos aquí de
poder cambiar la forma en que nuestros
alumnos están pensando sobre sí mismos y
sobre su manera de aprender y esto no
solamente sirve para matemáticas o para
ciencias sirve para la vida no para que
el alumno se conozca mejor y cambie la
perspectiva no de que a veces tienen ya
muy arraigada sobre el fracaso no sobre
el no poder y cambien ese switch a una
mentalidad de éxito
por favor no olviden registrarse en este
reto para el regreso a clases ustedes
pueden entrar al campeonato punto khan
academy punto org en esta página que
está hecha y crear especialmente para
este programa hay ustedes van a recibir
información si no se han registrado
pueden registrarse si éste quieren saber
más de las actividades de mentalidad de
crecimiento lo pueden hacer los voy a
llevar aquí
vamos abren una ventana y vamos a poner
el campeonato apuntó kan
a cada punto
org
y ustedes van a entrar aquí esta es la
página que van a entrar donde les dice
aquí pueden aprender más sobre las
mentales la mentalidad las actividades
de mentalidad de crecimiento aquí tienen
un vídeo de del fundador de khan academy
cómo funciona que tienen toda la
información para que puedan empezar
entonces no nos queda más que invitarlos
en motivarlos no a que sigan
por lo primero que va a felicitar los
precitados por su esfuerzo felicitarlos
por estar aquí porque ya el hecho de que
estén aquí en este webinar ya está
implicando esfuerzo y compromiso por
parte de ustedes entonces verdad quiero
felicitarlos porque ya desde ya son
campeones
y bueno motivarlos y de verdad
invitarlos a que se unan a este gran
reto es una manera estupenda de verdad
de comenzar el año escolar va a cambiar
mucho el tono no de nuestra clase y de
nuestras futuras clases dentro de stand
escolar quieres agregar algo más al
color
pues la verdad para todos los que
todavía no usan khan academy este los
invitamos a darle un vistazo y empezar
el año escolar con este reto creemos que
es una buena oportunidad para que
prueben y todos aquellos que ya nos
conocen y usan la plataforma sabemos que
están buscando cosas nuevas para motivar
a sus alumnos y que mejor que empezar
con un reto escolar en el cual tus
alumnos van ganando premios van este
este motivándose porque van viendo su
avance van progresando y pues van
creando estas mentalidades más fuertes
no entonces los invitamos a que
participen por favor
arrancamos el 10 de septiembre entonces
ahora todavía tienen tiempo de crear sus
clases echarle un vistazo al contenido
ir agregando a sus alumnos no se
presionen empezamos el 10 de septiembre
entonces todavía tienen tiempo de estar
viendo de qué se trata y vamos a obtener
otros dos webinars uno de mentalidad de
para hablar un poco más de este término
y otros sobre cuando bueno cuando ya
vayamos a empezar el reto el 10 de
septiembre vamos a hacer otro webinar en
el cual pues para todos aquellos son
nuevos y no han podido registrarse o no
han agregado su clase vamos a hacer una
sesión para todos ustedes entonces los
invitamos no se preocupen aquí estamos
para apoyarles y les mandamos un gran
saludo
muchas gracias por vernos y un abrazo a
todos y mucho éxito en este inicio de
clases en el inicio del periodo 2018
2019 cuídense saludos a todos chau